it's a feeling of joy we share with
millions of other families around the
world
meghan markle is making it clear she
wants the world to be a better place for
everyone
including her future daughter since the
pandemic began nearly five and a half
million women have lost work in the u.s
and 47 million more women around the
world
are expected to slip into extreme
poverty the duchess of sussex along with
her husband prince harry
served as co-chairs for global citizens
vax live concert benefit event which
aired on saturday
encouraging world leaders to make sure
covet 19 vaccines are accessible for all
if we work together to bring vaccines to
every country and continent
insist that vaccines are equitably
distributed and fairly priced
and ensure that governments around the
world are donating their additional
vaccines to countries in need
then we can begin to fully rebuild not
only to restore us to where we were
before
but to go further megan who's pregnant
with her and harry second child
a girl didn't attend the event but she
did appear via video to make a powerful
speech
she opened up about their daughter to be
and how she's inspiring her to empower
women around the world
when we think of her we think of all the
young women and girls around the globe
who must be given the ability and
support to lead us forward
prince harry the duke of sussex
harry appeared live in person he too
shared an impassioned speech
encouraging everyone to practice empathy
for those struggling with covet 19.
in reality and especially with this
pandemic
when any suffer we all suffer
we must look beyond ourselves with
empathy and compassion for those we know
and those we don't we need to lift up
all of humanity and make sure that no
personal community
is left behind the duke of sussex also
made it a point
to thank the frontline workers in the
audience and millions of others around
the globe
you spent the last year battling
courageously
and selflessly to protect us all you've
served
and sacrificed put yourselves in harm's
way
and acted with bravery knowing the cost
we owe you an incredible debt of
gratitude
thank you the royal couple has always
prioritized giving back to the community
on sunday megan and harry celebrated
mother's day by donating to harvest home
an organization that provides relief to
unhouse mothers and mothers to be
using their archwell foundation they
provided diapers
cleaning supplies and other essentials
the organization posted the news on
instagram with a personal message from
megan
writing quote as a mom and an expectant
mom
i deeply appreciate the significance of
community support
safe and accessible pregnancy resources
and trusted guidance in a nurturing
setting
thank you for all you do for the women
and mothers who are turned away
elsewhere at no fault of their own
you